DEVELOPMENTS OVERNIGHT
SURROUNDING THE JANUARY 6th
INSURRECTION.
JUST HOURS BEFORE THE NEXT
HEARING GETS UNDER WAY TODAY.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING
ON PREVIOUSLY UNDISCLOSED EMAILS
FROM TRUMP LAWYER JOHN EASTMAN
WHERE HE CLAIMS TO BE AWARE OF
A, QUOTE, HEATED FIGHT AMONG
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES OVER
WHETHER TO TAKE UP A CASE
INVOLVING THE 2020 ELECTION
RESULTS.
>> BUT MORE THAN THAT THE
"TIMES" REPORTS ON A RESPONSE TO
THAT EMAIL FROM ANOTHER PRO
TRUMP LAWYER SAYING, QUOTE, ODDS
OF ACTION BY THE SUPREME COURT
BEFORE JANUARY 6 WILL BECOME
MORE FAVORABLE IF THE JUSTICES
START TO FEAR THAT THERE WILL BE
WILD CHAOS ON JANUARY 6th UNLESS
THEY RULE BY THEN EITHER WAY.
THIS WAS ABOUT TWO WEEKS BEFORE
JANUARY 6.
THE "TIMES" SAYS THIS RAISES
QUESTIONS ABOUT A POSSIBLE LINK
TO THE IDEA OF THE VIOLENCE THAT
ULTIMATELY TOOK PLACE.
CNN'S KATELYN POLANTZ LIVE IN
WASHINGTON.
EXPLAIN TO US ABOUT THESE
REVELATIONS INVOLVED IN ALL OF
THESE EMAILS.
>> Reporter: HI.
SO THIS NEW STORY FROM "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" DESCRIBES EMAILS
BETWEEN TWO LAWYERS WHO WERE
WORKING WITH DONALD TRUMP AND
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AFTER THE
ELECTION.
THEY APPEAR TO REVEAL THAT ONE
LAWYER, JOHN EASTMAN, HE IS WELL
CONNECTED AMONG CONSERVATIVES,
FORMER SUPREME COURT CLERK, THAT
EAST MAN HAD INSIGHT INTO THE
INTERNAL DELIBERATIONS OF THE
SUPREME COURT AND ANOTHER LAWYER
WAS USING THAT INFORMATION WITH
HIM TO LOOK AT RAMPING UP THEIR
LEGAL BATTLE WITH AN EXPECTATION
OF CHAOS ON JANUARY 6.
SO IN THESE EMAILS "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" SAYS THAT EASTMAN ON
CHRISTMAS EVE 2020 WROTE, SO THE
ODDS ARE NOT BASED ON THE LEGAL
MERITS BUT AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
JUSTICES' SPINES AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
HEATED FIGHT UNDER WAY.
EASTMAN THEN SAYS FOR THOSE
WILLING TO DO THEIR DUTY, THAT
WOULD BE ON THE SUPREME COURT,
WE SHOULD HELP THEM BY GIVING
THEM A WISCONSIN CERT PETITION
TO ADD INTO THE MIX.
SO THAT APPEARS TO BE EASTMAN
USING HIS FAMILIARITY WITH THE
HIGH COURT TO PLOT OUT WHAT
DONALD TRUMP SHOULD DO TO TRY TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION RESULT.
AND THEN THIS SECOND LAWYER
COMES IN, HE IS ASSISTING THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN, TOO, HIS NAME IS
KENNETH CHESBRO, HE REPLIES TO
EASTMAN THAT THE ODDS OF ACTION
BEFORE JANUARY 6 WILL BECOME
MORE FAVORABLE IF THE JUSTICES
START TO FEAR THAT THERE WILL BE
WILD CHAOS ON JANUARY 6 UNLESS
THEY RULE BY THEN.
EITHER WAY.
SO YOU SEE THERE THAT ACCORDING
TO THIS REPORT THERE WAS
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW THIS EFFORT
BY TRUMP TO BLOCK THE ELECTION
USING THE COURTS COULD BE
CONSIDERED, AT THE SAME TIME
THAT THEY WERE EXPECTING HIS
SUPPORTERS TO DESCEND ON
WASHINGTON, THIS POTENTIALLY
INTIMIDATING MOMENT AND HOW
THOSE TWO PARTS OF THE PLAN WERE
SFITING TOGETHER.
THE "TIMES" ALSO SAYS THAT THE
EMAILS WERE OBTAINED BY THE
SELECT COMMITTEE WHEN THEY GOT
HUNDREDS OF EASTMAN EMAILS IN
RECENT WEEKS.
CNN HAS REACHED OUT TO THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE, THEY ARE NOT
COMMENTING ON THIS REPORT.
WE DO KNOW THAT TODAY THE
HOUSE'S PUBLIC HEARING WILL BE
FOCUSED ON THIS PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN AIMED AT THE VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE AND FROM
WHAT THE COMMITTEE HAS SAID
THEIR FINDINGS ABOUT PENCE ARE
AS MUCH ABOUT HIM AS THEY ARE
ABOUT WHAT EASTMAN WAS TRYING TO
DO ON BEHALF OF DONALD TRUMP.
WE WILL BE HEARING MORE ABOUT
EASTMAN TODAY AND ABOUT HIS
EMAILS.
>> IMPORTANT REPORTING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> LET'S BRING IN NOW OUR CNN
CHIEF LEGAL ANALYST AND FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR JEFFREY
TOOBIN.
THIS RAISES A LOT OF QUESTIONS,
SOME OF WHICH WE CAN'T ANSWER
YET, BUT HOW WOULD EASTMAN KNOW
ABOUT THE INTERNAL DELIBERATIONS
BEFORE THE SUPREME COURT OR WAS
HE BLUFFING?
WHERE WOULD YOU START LOOKING TO
TRY TO GET THIS ANSWER?
>> WELL, ONE THING WE KNOW FROM
VARIOUS REPORTING INCLUDING BY
CNN IS THAT EASTMAN HAS BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH GINNI THOMAS, THE
WIFE OF CLARENCE THOMAS, WHO WAS
VERY ACTIVE IN TRYING TO GET THE
RESULT OF THE ELECTION
OVERTURNED.
THE "TIMES" STORY DOES NOT SAY,
AND I WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR,
THAT GINNI THOMAS TOLD HIM ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON BEHIND THE
SCENES AT THE SUPREME COURT, BUT
IT CERTAINLY RAISES THAT
POSSIBILITY AND IT CERTAINLY
CRIES OUT FOR THE COMMITTEE TO
INTERVIEW GINNI THOMAS.
I MEAN, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY HAVE NOT DONE SO FAR, VERY
INTENTIONALLY, IS THEY HAVE NOT
REACHED OUT TO HER, BUT WHEN YOU
SEE THE SCOPE OF HER INVOLVEMENT
NOW AND THIS APPARENT INSIDE
INFORMATION THAT EASTMAN HAS,
AND MAYBE HE WAS JUST BLOWING
SMOKE, MAYBE HE DIDN'T KNOW
REALLY WHAT WAS GOING ON, BUT IN
LIGHT OF THE COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THEM IT CERTAINLY RAISES
THE QUESTION OF WHAT GINNI
THOMAS WAS TELLING EASTMAN AS
THEY MOVED THIS EFFORT FORWARD.
>> AND THEN, JEFFREY, THE OTHER
LAWYER INVOLVED HERE, THE OTHER
PRO TRUMP LAWYER KENNETH CHESBRO
TALKING ABOUT THE IDEA, THE
NOTION OF VIOLENCE THAT COULD
HAPPEN ON JANUARY 6th, A WEEK
BEFORE IT DOES.
IN A WAY DISCUSSING THE
STRATEGIC VALUE OF THAT
VIOLENCE.
WHAT ARE THE IMPLICATIONS THERE?
>> YOU KNOW, THIS IS JUST VERY
BIZARRE FOR ME BECAUSE KEN
CHESBRO WAS MY LAW SCHOOL
CLASSMATE, SOMEONE I HAVE KNOWN
FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
HE WAS KNOWN AS THE CHEESE IN
LAW SCHOOL AND HE IS SOMEONE WHO
HAS REALLY PRACTICED VERY MUCH
ON HIS OWN FOR MANY YEARS, HE
WORKED WITH LAURENCE TRIBE, THE
FAMOUS LIBERAL HARVARD LAW
PROFESSOR.
SO IT'S SURPRISING TO SEE HIM
INVOLVED IN THIS CONSERVATIVE
EFFORT, BUT, I MEAN, THIS IS A
DARK EMAIL BY SOMEONE
IMPLICATION.
I MEAN, IT CERTAINLY SUGGESTS
THAT IF THERE IS MORE CHAOS AND
MORE ACTIVITY AND POTENTIALLY
MORE VIOLENCE, THAT MAY HELP THE
TRUMP EFFORT.
NOW, THAT I WOULD HATE TO THINK
THAT'S WHAT HE'S SAYING BUT WHEN
YOU READ THE WORDS OF THOSE
EMAILS IT CERTAINLY -- THAT
EMAIL, IT SUGGESTS THAT THE
LEGAL EFFORT AND THE PROTEST
EFFORT AND THE EFFORT TO GET
INSIDE THE CAPITOL ARE MORE
CONNECTED THAN WE HAVE SEEN
BEFORE.
AGAIN, IT CRIES OUT FOR AN
INTERVIEW OF KEN CHESBRO AND
JOHN EASTMAN.
JOHN EASTMAN HAS BEEN TAKING THE
FIFTH, BUT, YOU KNOW, THESE
EMAILS ARE VERY SUGGESTIVE OF
REALLY A DARK EFFORT IN MANY
RESPECTS.
>> CERTAINLY THERE WAS SOME